[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
VIRGINIA MILLER: All right.
Hello, everyone.
It's good to see you all.
We're going to talk today about
cocktails and about Robert's
new book, which covers an
exciting change in the last,
actually, 20-plus years,
the Cocktail Renaissance,
the Cocktail Revival.
It goes by a few
different names,
depending on who you talk to.
But I thought we'd
start out by-- for those
who are aren't quite
sure what that means,
what is the Cocktail Renaissance
of the recent decades?
What is that exactly?
ROBERT SIMONSON: The
Cocktail Renaissance
has been this period
of time, which
has happened intensely
over the last 15 years
and somewhat less intensely
over the last 30 years,
where a group of bartenders sort
of reclaimed their profession,
bringing it back from just
a paycheck job, a place
holder that you did while you
were waiting to do something
else, and turning
it back into what
it had been in the late 19th
century and early 20th century,
a respected member
of the community
that had a set of skills
and that everyone looked up
to, and along with
that, figuring out
how to make the drinks and
the cocktails correctly,
how to make them with
quality products, with,
say, fresh juice
instead of sour mix,
with good spirits instead
of like bottom-shelf rotgut.
And so it all kind
of came together.
And it took a number of years,
but it finally got here.
It was the last thing to
be brought back and revived
properly in terms of
culinary aspects in America.
We went through the food
revolution and the beer
revolution and the
wine revolution,
but eventually we
got to cocktails.
And that is what the book
is about, how that happened,
why that happened,
and who was involved.
VIRGINIA MILLER: So why did you
decide to write this book now
at this particular time?
ROBERT SIMONSON: I decided I
wanted-- well, I didn't decide.
I wanted to write the
book four years ago,
and I went to my publisher,
and after a little convincing,
they said yes.
I wanted to write it because
I didn't see anyone else
writing it.
And I was afraid-- if you write
about liquor and cocktails,
and you particularly write from
an historical point of view,
you learn a few
things very quickly.
And one of the things is
that a lot of the history
wasn't written down.
All the "cocktail
historians," and there
are five or six of them
in the whole world,
they spent a lot of time
trying to figure out
where the cocktails came from,
the history of the bartender,
and they had to go
dig in old newspapers
and old out-of-print books,
and it took a very long time
to piece together this history.
It had all been lost.
And I found it
intolerable that we
would lose what had happened
in the last 30 years
just because-- I mean,
it's thoroughly documented
in the internet age,
but that doesn't
mean that everybody put all
the pieces together in one book
or document so that
people would remember it.
And as you can imagine,
history that is written in bars
gets forgotten, because
everyone's drinking.
And I experienced that as I
interviewed the bartenders
for this book.
Not everyone remembered
everything the same way.
And I had to figure out-- it
was like Rashomon all the time,
and it was like, OK,
what actually happened?
It's somewhere in
the middle there.
And I'm going to write it
down, and someone's not
going to be happy
with this account,
but it's as close as I
can get to the truth.
So that's why I
decided to do it.
VIRGINIA MILLER: So if you had
to pinpoint a time and please,
where and when would you say
the cocktail revival started?
ROBERT SIMONSON: It's a
little difficult to say.
And it's different
for every city.
The book concentrates basically
on three cities, New York,
San Francisco, and London, as
being the major cities that
got the cocktail revival going.
And in each city,
it began differently
and at different times.
If you're talking
about New York,
it really kind of
kicked off when
a man named Dale
de Groff was asked
to take charge of the cocktail
program in the Rainbow Room
when they reopened the Rainbow
Room at the top of Rockefeller
Center in 1987.
He kind of worked in isolation
for a very long time.
Some people were paying
attention to what he did,
and a lot of people
wrote about it,
but there wasn't another
important cocktail
bar in New York until Milk
and Honey, which some of you
might have heard of, a very
famous bar in the Lower
East Side that kicked off
the whole Speakeasy thing.
It came along in 2000.
Here in San Francisco,
it's even more complicated.
There were some early figures.
There was a guy named
Tony Abou-Ganim, who
got his start at the Balboa
Cafe that some of you
may have heard of.
And then he was the head
bartender when they open
reopened the Starlight Room at
the top of the Francis Drake
Hotel.
And the Starlight Room was
sort of like the Rainbow Room
here, right,
basically, isn't it?
VIRGINIA MILLER:
Yeah, upscale hotel.
ROBERT SIMONSON: And they did
the same thing that the Rainbow
Room did, is that they put
the bartender on a pedestal.
And they said, pay
attention to this guy.
He knows what he's doing
as much as our chef does.
So Tony Abou-Ganim was one
of the guys who got it going.
And we're talking
in the late '90s.
And then there was another
guy named Paul Harrington, who
worked at the
townhouse in Emeryville
and Enrico's when
it used to exist.
And he was a real
cocktail scholar.
All these people
without exception
would seek out the old books
that had gone out of print when
Prohibition came and then
he would comb through them
and try to figure out, well,
how do I make a Widow's Kiss
and how do I make
a Sidecar correctly
so that it tastes good?
He was in it a
relatively short period.
He wanted to be an architect.
And so by the mid '90s he had
left the profession completely.
But he left his mark.
They made mojitos like
crazy at Enrico's.
And that doesn't sound so
exciting right now, but once
upon a time, a mojito
was a revelation,
that you'd actually take
fresh vegetables and herbs
and put them at the
bottom of the glass
and muddle them and create
these things one by one by one.
And he got a lot of
attention, Paul Harrington,
because the press liked to
hang out at Enrico's and drink.
And in particular,
important to his career,
was that the
journalists that went on
to create "Wired" magazine
used to hang out there.
And so when they
started "Wired" and they
created the website for
"Wired," which I believe
was the first professional
website connected
to a publication, they asked
him to write a cocktail column
in it.
It was called
"CocktailTime.com,"
and this started
in like '95 or '96.
And this started a long
connection between the cocktail
revival and the rise
of the internet.
These two are very
interconnected.
Without the internet,
the cocktail revival
wouldn't have happened.
It wouldn't have
happened as quickly.
Would you agree, Virginia?
VIRGINIA MILLER: Absolutely.
Is so widespread now.
Every state now you can
go and find amazing bars,
and I think that's largely
to do with the internet.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Yeah.
One of the reasons why cocktail
bartending had stagnated
is because everybody was
working in isolation.
Like if you're trying to make
a good Manhattan in Seattle,
you don't know if
someone's having
that same problem in Atlanta.
But once the
internet comes along,
you get on the chat rooms,
you exchange recipes,
you exchange thoughts,
and a community develops.
VIRGINIA MILLER: So in terms
of New York and London,
you mentioned Dale de Groff, but
who were some other key figures
kind of in those early days that
really pushed things forward?
ROBERT SIMONSON: In New York?
VIRGINIA MILLER:
Yeah, in New York,
and then maybe we can talk
about London, too, a little bit,
since it was so important.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
Well, Dale de Groff
was an interesting figure.
How many people have heard
the name Dale de Groff?
OK, see, bartenders aren't
famous the way chefs are.
They just aren't.
Dale de Groff is the most
famous bartender in the nation,
and he's not that
famous, you know?
That's just the way it is.
He's been bartending
his whole life.
He's 68.
He's a very charismatic guy.
He's a former actor.
He used to bartend at
the Bel Air down in LA.
And the thing
about Dale de Groff
is he seems to have never spent
a night at home in the past 40
years.
And so all through
the book are stories
where young bartenders
trying to figure out
their lives and
their professions,
and all of a sudden,
Dale de Groff
walks into their
bar out of the blue.
And he goes, hey, how you doing?
I hear you're making cocktails.
What can I tell you?
How can I help?
Here-- here's a book.
And so this happened
again and again and again.
And so he developed
proteges in this way.
So his three major
proteges in New York
was a woman named Julie Reiner,
who actually is from Hawaii
and spent several years
bartending in San Francisco
before she moved to New York.
She's a woman who started
a famous bar called
Flatiron Lounge and
one called Clover Club.
There was another
woman from Long Island
named Audrey Saunders.
She had a business
cleaning carpets
at offices and
celebrities' homes.
And strangely enough,
she didn't like that job,
and she wanted to
do something else.
So she went to one of Dale
de Groff's classes and said,
I'll work for you for free.
I just want to do
something else.
I love bartending.
And she did work for
free for many years,
and then she opened a
bar called the Pegu Club.
And then there was a New
Yorker named Sasha Petraske.
He's the man who
founded Milk and Honey.
And he was an
interesting fellow.
He grew up in Greenwich Village.
He grew up in a
communist household,
so he had a very interesting
perspective on capitalism.
And also during the weekends
he saw the bridge and tunnel
people come in and trash his
neighborhood every weekend,
and he said, one day I'm
going to open a bar where
we don't have an effect
on the neighbors.
And that's what he did.
He created this secret bar, and
you had to know it was there.
It had no address.
You didn't know where it was.
You had to text in order
to get a reservation,
then he'd text back and
say it was OK to come.
This of, course, made a
very notorious and catnip
for the media.
So those were three
of the early figures.
Here in San Francisco, there
was a man named Scott Beatty.
There's a restaurant called
Cyrus up in Healdsville?
VIRGINIA MILLER: Healdsburg.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Healdsburg.
VIRGINIA MILLER: It was, yeah.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Any of
you guys ever been there?
Anyway, for its time, it
was a famous restaurant
along the lines of
French Laundry, right?
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah, fine
dining, tasting menus only,
yeah.
It was woderful.
ROBERT SIMONSON: He took
advantage of his surroundings.
He figured, I'm in Napa
Valley, and everybody
has these wonderful
herbs and orange groves
and fruit groves and vegetables,
and I'm going to take all this
and just stuff it
into the glass.
So his cocktails were
like works of art.
They had like wheels of orange
and tufts of mint and tufts
of rosemary, and it
was like chartreuse
in a glass, every
single cocktail.
So he was important, and he got
one of the first book deals.
And then there was a guy named
Marco Dionysos, who actually
was from-- he wasn't
from Portland,
but he made his
name in Portland.
This was before Portland
was cool like it is today.
And he was impatient, so he
came down to San Francisco,
and he started the
cocktail program at a place
called Absinthe,
which still exists.
That was the first really
important modern craft cocktail
program in San Francisco.
It was 1997.
Every drink on the
menu had a heritage.
It had the date it was created,
who created it, what was in it.
And that really turned a
corner in San Francisco.
There's always been
a big difference
between the San Francisco
scene and the New York scene.
As Camper English, a
journalist friend of ours,
put it rather derogatorily,
the New York bartenders just
pour things out of
bottles, and that's
what they know how to
do, whereas you guys
use fresh produce
and know how it
changes from season to season,
week to week, to day to day.
And that changes the
way you make cocktails.
So it's all about freshness.
That has changed a little
bit over the years.
There's a kind of
a sameness now.
Everyone makes
the same cocktails
wherever you go in America.
But there's still a little
bit of that in San Francisco,
isn't there?
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah.
We just have so
much accessibility,
so we get spoiled that way.
And I think there's more to
play with throughout the year.
And it's like, what kind
of lemon are you using?
Is it Meyer?
Is it--?
We get down into those details,
where you don't see that
as much in other bars.
They don't get quite as geeky
about every single detail.
But it does happen.
And there's very spiritus
bars here as well
that are just booze
out of a bottle as well
and focus that way.
So it goes both ways.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Yes,
including all the whisky bars.
The whisky revival is part and
parcel with the whole cocktail
revival.
The bourbon and rye
people saw what bartenders
were doing and said, oh, people
actually care about our spirits
now.
And they want good bourbon,
and they want good rye,
and they will use
it in cocktails.
So it's kind of they walked
hand in hand into this.
VIRGINIA MILLER: I
think that's maybe one--
not to detour too much,
but one interesting subject
is how it's changed
the spirits world as
well over the last
decade-plus, is there
are so many more distillers
now, dozens, hundreds more.
And also the price of
spirits has gone up so much
for those of us that follow it.
But I don't know if there's any
like whisky fans or collectors
or the rest here, but I think
that's one interesting change
that's happened that really
is due to the cocktail revival
as well in a large part.
There's a greater
demand for all of this.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
And a lot of that
started out here
on the West coast,
a lot of those microdistillers.
And when these
microdistillers got started,
they really wanted
to get their products
in the hands of these
bartender influencers,
because they became influencers.
The liquor companies started
going to the bartenders
and saying, what do you
think of my new product?
Do you like it?
Should I back to
the drawing board?
Will you carry it?
Will you use it?
As opposed to like 25 years
ago, when they would say,
I got a new product.
You should carry it.
And I'll buy you a television.
[LAUGHING] And that's all they
cared about their opinion.
They didn't think much of them.
So it's really
changed everything.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah.
And there's those key St.
George and Hubert Germain-Robin,
or Germain-Robin
craft distillers now,
but those, back since the
'80s here in the Bay Area,
have been so important.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Indeed.
VIRGINIA MILLER: And there's
so much about seasonality
and local sourcing for
their gins and rest
as well, or the grapes
that Germain-Robin
are grown around the
vineyards in [INAUDIBLE].
So I feel like all this has
trickled into many areas,
but yeah, actually, that's one
thing I was thinking about.
How would you say
this has trickled down
across the country?
Because of course, then
there's these cities
we don't think of for cocktails,
like Tulsa or the rest,
but we can go middle
America and find speakeasies
and these kinds of bars now.
So how do you think
the rest of the country
specifically has been
affected by what has really
started on the coasts?
ROBERT SIMONSON: Well,
like with a lot of things,
the middle of America
looks to the coasts
to see what they're doing, and
they take their tips culturally
and culinarily from there.
And so it would trickle.
It's not trickle down.
It's like trickle in, into
the rest of the country.
And so after San
Francisco and New
York started getting their thing
going, then Chicago did and LA.
And now you get the secondary
cities and the tertiary cities,
where you can find one or two
or three good cocktail bars.
And it's kind of funny.
They have to go through
the same growing pains.
They start off rather
self-important and pretentious,
just like New York
and San Francisco
were at the beginning.
And then they eventually figure
out that doesn't work so well,
and then they get back
to the hospitality part.
They just have to go
through the same baby steps
over and over again.
I'm sure you've had
this experience going
to other cities.
And it's just like, oh, how this
feels like San Francisco five
years ago.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah.
I'll say, oh, they just
got their first speakeasy.
And it's a real snobby and
passwords and exclusive.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
Yes, and they're
making a barrel-aged cocktail.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah,
or you think like Denver
with Sean Kenyon, who's a
major figure in the cocktail
world and a bar manager there.
He had a speakeasy a few years
ago and took Denver by storm.
And now I go back, and
he's opened the Occidental.
And it's arcade games and
flat screens with sports.
And they kind of go
through that phase
where, well, we were
snobby and fancy,
and now we're just over it.
So you see that.
But New York and San Francisco
have gone through those phases
a few times over, I'd say.
What are some specific
bars around the country
that have been really surprising
or unexpected for you?
ROBERT SIMONSON:
Surprising or unexpected?
Hm.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Stood out.
ROBERT SIMONSON: I mean,
you have to go through time,
and like there was a time
where the so-called molecular
mixology bars were surprising
because they were doing
outlandish things with
flames and hydrogen.
And like what's-- is there
a proponent in San Francisco
of that style?
VIRGINIA MILLER:
There really wasn't.
There was a couple people
that tried to start it,
and it never really took.
San Francisco didn't find
it quite real enough.
I kind of wish it would have,
just as another element, but--
ROBERT SIMONSON: Yeah.
Has anyone ever been to a
place called Aviary in Chicago?
Yeah, there you go.
So they go to great
lengths to make a cocktail.
It's amazing.
It's like every cocktail
is a science experiment.
And those kind of bars
are good in their way.
I mean, as long as
the drinks taste good,
who cares how they made them?
And surprise?
Well, and then cocktail bars,
it became such a big business
that they became
events, event bars.
I mean, the interior
design was done
within an inch of its life,
and there was usually a theme.
The epitome of this is this
bar in New York called the Dead
Rabbit Grog and Grocery.
And they wanted to
create this bar that
was supposed to be like
1850s in New York City.
And on the bottom
part it was like where
like the young immigrant
Irish toughs would drink,
and they'd have their
whisky and beer.
And then if you were
like a bon vivant who
had like a diamond stickpin in
your tie, you'd go upstairs,
and you'd have the
fancy-dancy cocktails.
And it's done very well.
And it's quite an experience.
And the cocktails are good.
It does kind of feel like a
theme park every now and then.
The same people have opened
a place called Blacktail
recently, which is supposed
to be like what a bar would be
in Havana during Prohibition.
So there's always been
this big fantasy element.
Because we're all
just trying to imagine
what drinking used to be.
[LAUGHTER]
And that's why bartenders,
they couldn't help themselves.
They get the vest.
They get the mustache wax.
Tattoos are modern.
But anyway, they were
dressing the part.
And it can seem foolish,
but you have to remember,
it's just like dress the
part, be the part if you're
going to embrace this.
And if you're going
to ask for respect,
it's like, I'm a
bartender, look at me,
this is what a
bartender dresses like.
They eventually are
stopping dressing like that,
but there's nothing
wrong with a bartender
looking spiffy behind the bar.
VIRGINIA MILLER:
Well, and I find
there's a part of it
that, like you said,
it gets a little silly,
and it's trendy for sure.
But I've always been kind
of a retro, old-school girl,
and I think one thing I love
is that this crowd draws people
who really respect the past.
There's a lot of geeks, and
they dig into their history.
And so sometimes that
translates to dress.
And they listen to a lot of
jazz, and they collect vinyl.
And I find it attracts
that kind of person.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Vinyl
does seem to be a big thing
in the bartender world.
VIRGINIA MILLER:
It's not a given,
but it does seem to
attract that crowd.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Well, it's
all about authenticity.
They're just chasing after that.
So we were asked to talk about
how you can know whether you're
in a good bar or not,
just some ways like
if you walk into
these cocktail bars,
it can be a little intimidating.
And that's a shame.
It shouldn't be that at all.
Remember, they're
there to serve you.
They want you there.
And they want you to
be happy and come back.
But they look beautiful.
The bartenders are
sometimes dressed very well.
Everything about a bartender
is intimidating in a way.
He's standing-- he's in
charge, or she's in charge.
But there are also a lot
of charlatans out there
and a lot of wannabes and
people who are doing it wrong.
And what's Wayne Curtis' phrase?
All mustache, no merit.
[LAUGHTER]
So what would be the first
thing-- you go to more bars
than I do, I think.
Because you're just on the
road all the time, and you
see more cities.
What's the first thing you
look for when you go in a bar?
How do you know you're
in the right place?
VIRGINIA MILLER:
Well, I actually
check the websites ahead of
time and look at the menu.
And I get frustrated if I
can't see an example of a menu,
because I just want to look
for either a little originality
or a focus with a cocktail menu.
If I start to feel like
it's all over the place
or looks like a copycat
of everything else,
then I start to worry.
ROBERT SIMONSON: That
they've pieced together
their menu from other people's
menus by looking on the web?
VIRGINIA MILLER:
Or a consultant,
which is a thing these days.
Cocktail consultants
are a dime a dozen.
And they come in
put together menus.
And there's not really a bar
manager necessarily doing that.
But when I walk
into the bar, I'm
looking-- I love both
dives and upscale bars,
so I actually look at the
spirits behind the bar.
I look to see, is it a
thoughtful selection?
Do they have a nice mix
of small and big brands,
obscure spirits?
Or if they're focused on
Italian amaro, let's say,
is it just Fernet and
a couple big-- Cynar,
or do they have a
broader range if they
claim to have that focus.
So I kind of look for
those kinds of things.
ROBERT SIMONSON: I
look at back bar,
too, although sometimes
it's a case of they've
collected all the
right tools but they
don't know how to use them.
VIRGINIA MILLER: That's right.
ROBERT SIMONSON: So you
have to look out for that.
I was talking with some
bartenders recently,
and they were saying that
they thought the two most
important things in a bar--
it doesn't have anything to do
with the drinks or the menu.
You walk in, and it's the
music and the lighting,
if the music seems
thoughtful and right
for the place, if it's not
too loud, that it actually
contributes and
doesn't take away
from the idea of conversation,
and if the lighting makes
the bar look attractive,
but more importantly makes
the people in the
bar look attractive.
[LAUGHTER]
Then you know that they've
thought through everything.
And then as we were
talking, we came up
with a third thing,
which is actually
as important-- temperature.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah!
It's true.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Who wants to
be in a hot bar or an incredibly
chilly bar?
It's got to be the
perfect, right temperature.
Because that puts you at ease.
Why do you go into a bar?
To relax at the end of a day.
If the temperature is wrong,
you're not going to do that.
So those are some
things I look for.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah.
And service, right?
ROBERT SIMONSON:
Service, of course.
VIRGINIA MILLER: This is
a whole big discussion.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
You should be given
a greeting within-- how long?
30 seconds, I think.
VIRGINIA MILLER:
Ideally right away.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Yeah.
You walk in.
That bartender better see
you, and if they're busy,
just say, hello,
be right with you.
If you're sitting at
the stool for like five
minutes and nobody's
acknowledging you,
you already feel bad, and
they've already failed.
And also not just the hello, but
you don't have your drink yet,
but cocktail napkin
right in front of you.
Somebody put this really well.
I forget who it was.
That's your patch
of real estate.
They've given you a piece
of land in their bar.
It belongs to you.
There's going to be a drink
on that cocktail napkin.
And so you feel like
you're part of the bar.
So there is that,
and glass of water.
Bars where you keep
ordering drinks
and you still don't
get the glass of water,
it's either one of two things.
They are inattentive,
they're not doing their job,
or they're cheap.
They don't want
to give you water
because they want you to
order only drinks that
actually cost money.
VIRGINIA MILLER:
Or there's a crowd,
which we do face in California.
But still, you're supposed
to get it if you ask for it.
ROBERT SIMONSON: If
you ask for it, OK.
So do bars not do it out
of conscientiousness here?
VIRGINIA MILLER:
Yeah, it's true.
But you are supposed to ask
and then get it right away.
So we've been going through
that the last year-plus.
Yeah.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Oh,
that's interesting.
Yes, they did ask
last night whether I
wanted a glass of water.
VIRGINIA MILLER: So that's why.
But yeah, I prefer it when
they ask me, actually,
because then I don't
have to think about it.
ROBERT SIMONSON: As far
as the menu is concerned,
when I go to a new bar and
I feel duty-bound to order
their original drinks because
that's the flag they've
put in the sand--
there's a certain way
that people read menus.
And their eyes go to
the top left corner.
And so find the drink there.
That drink is
there for a reason.
Either they're really proud
of it, they think it's good,
and you should drink it.
Or they think it's going to
have a lot of public appeal
and a lot of people
are going to order it.
It's a good way to get
a gauge on the place.
OK, this is their badge.
This is what they're saying.
We serve this kind of thing.
So I always start there.
So that's a good tip.
VIRGINIA MILLER: That's
one of my rules of thumb,
too, because it's
like a restaurant.
You're not going to go
to a Peruvian restaurant
and then ask for
something that's Mexican.
So I kind of think
the same with the bar.
It's like, well,
what's your specialty.
It's like that's what
I want to focus on.
But of course, I
drink everything,
so I guess if there's
something you hate,
you want to outline
that to them.
But I think it's a
good question to ask.
ROBERT SIMONSON: It's a
good idea to read the bar.
Not every bar is right
for the same thing.
So if you go into a
sports bar and they've
got the latest game
on and you go up
and you order, what, a Sidecar?
VIRGINIA MILLER:
A Ramos Gin Fizz?
ROBERT SIMONSON: Yes, or a
Ramos Gin Fizz, you're an idiot.
You're gonna have a bad time.
[LAUGHTER]
They're going to make
you a bad Ramos Gin Fizz,
they're going to hate you
because you asked for a Ramos
Gin Fizz when you
walked into a sports bar
and instead of getting beer.
So just get a beer.
But if you go into
a cocktail bar,
and they're obviously
proud, and it's like,
we make cocktails well,
then you order a cocktail.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Then you
ask for a vodka tonic.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Yeah, you
can ask for a vodka-- no,
they should make you the vodka
tonic, and they should smile.
But why not take advantage
of what the bar is?
It's like not every bar is for
every occasion or every mood.
VIRGINIA MILLER: That's right.
ROBERT SIMONSON: So, yes.
So it's somewhat
up to you as well
if you're going to have
a good time in your bar.
VIRGINIA MILLER: And we
have a few more minutes
before we'll take questions.
But maybe getting into some
specifics with San Francisco,
lets talk a few specific bars.
What do you think in terms
of iconic or longtime bars?
What are ones that have made
a real impression on you here?
ROBERT SIMONSON: The
important cocktail bars,
for some reason they have tended
not to stick around as much
here.
Bar Agricole is a restaurant,
but it's an important bar.
It's run by a guy
named Thad Vogler, who
also owns Trou Normand.
He's a very opinionated,
very principled guy.
He only carries
liquors and spirits
that he approves of, not just
taste-wise but ethically,
the way it's made and
where it comes from.
And so when you look
at his back bar,
there aren't many
bottles back there,
and you probably don't
know any of them.
I mean, he says, if it's a big
brand and it's well advertised,
chances are it's probably bad.
And he has his own
way of doing things.
So I think he sets up a really
interesting example, one
that I don't think many follow,
because it's too difficult.
Trick Dog is an important
bar that our friend over here
has discovered by
accident and found
that every drink she ordered
was excellent, correct?
That's by a group called
the Bon Vivants, which
is made of three gentlemen.
Is that right?
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah,
it started that way.
And now they've got a whole
staff around the country.
But all San Francisco guys
started it originally.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
It's a good example
of a bar that has tried to
do things very well, very
exquisitely, but putting
on no airs, no pretension.
It just feels like a bar
when you go in there.
You just can get
really great drinks.
And they also have
these thematic menus
that they bring out with a lot
of fanfare every six months.
The current one is based on
politics, presidential politics
or something like that.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Right.
I haven't seen this one yet,
but yeah, the past ones--
ROBERT SIMONSON: They've
had based on the Zodiac.
They had a menu that
looked like a Chinese--
VIRGINIA MILLER:
Chinese food menu.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
VIRGINIA MILLER: Dog calendar.
The first one was
based on a Pantone paint wheel.
And each cocktail was named
after one of the weird colors
that the--
VIRGINIA MILLER:
You got a swatch
when you got in the bar with
your drink on each-- yeah.
ROBERT SIMONSON: So I think
they've been influential,
not just in terms of
the way they do things,
but also they've got
a lot of attention.
They're kind of a good blueprint
on how you become a nationally
famous bar in a city.
VIRGINIA MILLER: But I think
one thing with the Bon Vivants
is they've been very
humanitarian focused
or giving-back focused as well.
So they've gotten a lot
of attention for that.
They've thrown these Pig and
Punch, now Swig and Swine--
ROBERT SIMONSON: Swig and
Swine, Pig and Punch, yeah.
So they do charitable events.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah, that
they're famous for as well.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
They're festivals
that I have roast pig
and punch, lots of punch.
And historically speaking, there
is a restaurant in Richmond
called Tommy's
Mexican Restaurant.
AUDIENCE: [WHISTLING] Who
ROBERT SIMONSON: Whistled?
AUDIENCE: Me!
ROBERT SIMONSON: Yay!
If you want to know
why you're able to get
better tequila or better
mezcal these days,
that restaurant is a
big part of the answer.
The owner, Julio Bermejo,
started making his margaritas
with 100% agave tequila instead
of like crappy tequila back
in the early '90s.
And he got rid of the triple
sec because he wanted people
to taste the tequila and
not taste anything else.
And that became the
Tommy's Margarita.
And the Tommy's Margarita is
served all over the nation.
So he became an
evangelist for tequila,
which back in the '80s and
'90s was thought of as,
I don't know, like a bad
choice, the kind of choice
you made late at night, and
you drank too much of it,
and you felt bad in the morning,
and you never drank it again.
It was a dangerous spirit
that college students drank.
But now it's become respected,
and people sip a tequila,
and they talk about it.
And they even drink
mezcal, and they
know that it doesn't
have to have a worm in it
and kind of thing.
So if you haven't been, go.
It's mediocre Mexican food, but
you can get a Tommy's Margarita
made at Tommy's.
And they have the best selection
of tequila in the city,
don't they?
VIRGINIA MILLER: Oh, yeah.
It's over 300 was the
last count I heard.
But I think it's more than that.
And they have a lot of
things under the shelf
that are no longer being made.
So if you just ask for the
special off-the-rack stuff
for the things you can't
see from behind the bar,
they can offer you some
very special tequilas.
ROBERT SIMONSON: San
Francisco is a cool place,
because unlike New
York, you never
really forgot cocktail culture.
It was on a low flame,
but it kept burning
through the '70s and '80s.
There were places, if
you wanted to find them,
that made good cocktails.
And there are places
like the Buena
Vista is famous for one
cocktail, the Irish Coffee.
And so it held onto
it a little bit.
And there's always
been a big history
here with spirits from
Latin America, like tequila.
And also because of
the Italian population,
people have always
drunk Negronis here
and things like that.
So it's a special place
bar-wise and drinking-wise.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah.
And there are bars like
Zam Zam that have been
going strong since the '40s.
ROBERT SIMONSON: I
haven't been there yet.
VIRGINIA MILLER:
Oh, my goodness.
You should go.
It's very special.
Has anyone else been to Zam Zam?
Yes?
OK, great.
ROBERT SIMONSON: And
like the Tonga Room--
that's an old tiki place.
VIRGINIA MILLER:
Yeah, Tonga Room
was designed by a Hollywood
guy back in the '40s,
and it looks like a movie set.
It's pretty understandable.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Is
that Steve Crane place?
VIRGINIA MILLER: No.
Well, it's a hotel.
It's a pretty hotel
kind of situation.
So the drinks aren't-- they had
a revamp a couple years ago.
Don Ronan helped them, consulted
with the Fairmont Hotels.
But it's not the best drinks,
and they're expensive,
but he improved
them quite a bit.
But the space is one of a kind.
They say it's the last in the
country left of those great,
expansive-- it's got a pool in
the middle where a boat floats
back and forth with a band
on it and plays yacht rock.
[LAUGHING] And it
looks like you've
stepped into a tiki movie set.
I guess that's one other
aside, because that
has some strong ties
locally, but the tiki revival
has kind of brought-- rum has
been the latest craze, I'd say,
the last two, three
years around the country?
ROBERT SIMONSON:
Yeah, tiki drinks
are one of the last
category of cocktails
to be brought back,
because they had been
in eclipse for many decades.
And people, even
bartenders, mixologists,
tended to think of them as
silly, sugary, rummy drinks
with umbrellas in them.
And we're trying to get
people to respect us,
and they're not gonna
respect us if we give them
a drink with an umbrella in it.
But there was a historian
named Geoff Berry who
did the research and
got the original recipes
for all these old tiki
drinks like the Mai Tai
and the Zombie and
the Pain Killer.
And once he got the
real raw material,
everyone started to see,
oh, yes, these were actually
once well-crafted drinks.
They weren't crap made with sour
mix and bad rum and Bacardi.
Sorry, Bacardi.
VIRGINIA MILLER: [LAUGHING]
ROBERT SIMONSON: And the
greatest, shining example
of the tiki revival
here in town, Smuggler's
Cove-- you will see it
in all its glory there.
And I believe there's another
tiki bar, opened recently
by the Future Bars?
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yes,
that's Pagan Idol.
That one is in the
financial district.
And it's a crazy
environment, too.
It's got pyrotechnic kind
of lights and a volcano
in the back, and the front
area looks like a ship,
the hull of a ship.
It's pretty fun in there.
ROBERT SIMONSON: It is.
It is.
And also, I mean, I think
now it's kind of turned over
on its head.
The cocktail revival
owes a lot to tiki.
People have been going
crazy with garnishes lately.
Like the creativity has
gone from inside the glass
to outside the glass.
And that's totally
taken from tiki.
And also, with all
these thematic bars
like Dead Rabbit and Black
Tail, it's a fantasy world,
and tiki was always about that.
You walk in, and it's like
you're not in San Francisco
anymore.
You're on some Pacific isle.
So that's that.
VIRGINIA MILLER:
And I was going say,
historically, actually,
talking about tiki,
the roots are from
California, both here
and Don the Beachcomber.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
Los Angeles, yes.
Yes, San Francisco,
home of Trader Vic's.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Is
everyone familiar with--
ROBERT SIMONSON: Anyone ever
been to the Trader Vic's
in Emeryville?
Any good?
Should I visit?
Yes?
OK.
VIRGINIA MILLER: It's historic.
I guess this is disputed,
but supposedly the invention
of the Mai Tai was Trader Vic's.
ROBERT SIMONSON: That's
not disputed, no.
It's his.
VIRGINIA MILLER: It's a
style of Mai Tai, right?
Some people claim to--
ROBERT SIMONSON: Well,
Don the Beachcomber
claimed that Trader
Vic's stole it from him,
but most historians
side with Trader Vic.
Mai Tai is his.
It's his.
VIRGINIA MILLER:
It's Bay Area, yeah.
ROBERT SIMONSON: OK.
So why don't we
open to questions?
Anybody have any
questions about anything?
AUDIENCE: So everything is craft
now, craft this, craft that.
What about these
things like tonic
and these other categories
that people are going craft in?
Is that really like
elevating drinks?
Or have we gone too far,
sort of down the craft road?
ROBERT SIMONSON: Well,
taking tonic as an example,
I'd say yes.
I know people get annoyed
by the craft term now.
It just means that they're
taking a little care
to make it, as opposed to
some assembly-line process.
The tonic water
that we were using
from Canada Dry or Schweppes, it
didn't have any quinine in it.
And it was very sweet.
If you've ever been
to London and had
the tonic water over there,
it's more dry and bitter.
So have you had like a gin and
tonic with like store bought
and then one of
the fancier brands?
AUDIENCE: No.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Compare
them side by side
and see what you think.
AUDIENCE: What do you think?
ROBERT SIMONSON: I think one
with like-- there's Q Tonic,
there's Fever Tree tonic.
There are actually quite
a few at this point.
And you do have to pay a little
extra for it, because they
are small businesses.
I won't drink a gin and tonic
with like Canada Dry anymore.
It doesn't taste good.
I mean, it just taste sort
of like a little sweet, kind
of soda-y beverage.
In some cases, though, the craft
thing always goes overboard.
I'm not exactly sure whether
we need craft simple syrup.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, simple syrup
is sugar and water.
I can make some right here.
[LAUGHTER]
And it tastes as good as
anything you buy on the shelf.
So--
AUDIENCE: Bit, I mean, if
you're using craft sugar--
ROBERT SIMONSON: Aha.
[LAUGHTER]
But simple syrup goes
inside a cocktail.
And once it gets in there,
are you really going
to notice that taste anymore?
It's sort of like the
vodka in a Cosmopolitan.
You can use Belvedere,
Gray Goose, whatever
you want to use, Smirnoff.
Once it's in the cocktail,
you lose all those nuances.
It's just vodka.
AUDIENCE: The top-left
menu thing was cool.
Do you have any
other tips and tricks
to navigating cocktail menus?
Like I always feel like I
sort of like everything,
and so I look at a menu,
and I'm like, I don't know.
I have no idea how to
figure out what to order.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
The menus can be
pretty large and intimidating.
Do you have a general
idea of the kind
of things you like to drink?
Or do you like to
drink most things?
AUDIENCE: That's what
bartenders always ask.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT SIMONSON: Well, yeah, no.
That's true.
They're trying to be
helpful, but I, too,
get annoyed by that question.
It's like, what
do you recommend?
And they throw it
right back at you.
Well, what do you like to drink?
And it's like-- and
I always tell them
I like to drink
everything, because I do.
And I really just want to know
what they think they make well.
But they're not going
to tell you that.
I wish they'd be more
honest, like, you know,
I really like this drink.
I think it's spectacular.
We do this well.
I guess you just have to
throw it back in their lap.
But they also do
hate that question.
Don't ask them,
what do you drink?
They hate that question.
How do you crack that nut?
VIRGINIA MILLER: I do.
I push it back on them.
I don't ask them
what they drink,
because they do hate that.
But I'll say, what
do you think's
really exciting on
your menu right now?
Or sometimes even, what is the
most popular drink on your menu
right now?
So I can see what
everyone's ordering if it's
my first time at the bar.
But that's not always the most
interesting to me, either.
What's popular might
be the vodka drink,
and I don't want that.
But I ask those questions,
and I'll kind of
dig a little deeper.
Or if they force me
to, I'll pick a mood
and go, well, you
know, something bitter
sounds great right now.
And then we narrow
it down to a couple.
ROBERT SIMONSON: If you
give the bartender a sign
that you're inquisitive
and you're really
thinking about your
order, then choose
a couple drinks on the menu
that are intriguing to you
and ask about a specific
ingredient in them.
And then the bartender says,
OK, we've got a thinker.
All right, we're going to have
a little conversation here.
And you'll learn more,
and pretty quickly,
I'd say probably
within a minute,
you'll be able to decide where
you want to go with your order.
AUDIENCE: What do you think
are the most important things
to have stocked
in your home bar?
ROBERT SIMONSON:
Important things
to have stocked in our home bar?
AUDIENCE: In like
my own home bar.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
In your home bar.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
Which, just so you
know, is very minimal.
But like in like your
own personal collection
if you're trying--
ROBERT SIMONSON: Do you
like to drink cocktails?
AUDIENCE: I am learning
more about them.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: Which is why
this has been helpful.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
Well, I guess you
start with the things
you like to drink.
So, say, if you like
Martinis, then you
want to get some gin and some
vermouth in your back bar.
I mean, it's just--
you sort of should
start in a small, narrow place.
Like if suddenly you just
decide, I'm a Negroni girl,
I'm mad about
Negronis, so you're
going to want the gin
and the sweet vermouth
and the Campari
there all the time.
And then eventually, probably
you'll get enough Negronis.
Let's see what else I like.
And as you drink new drinks,
you say, I like those,
so let's all have those.
What do you think?
VIRGINIA MILLER:
I think sometimes
if you want a
little variety, too,
there's this simple-- like
limes are kind of genius
for a few key cocktails.
So it's like let's say you
have a bottle of tequila,
a bottle of gin,
and a bottle of rum.
You got some limes, and you
make some simple syrup, which
I make and keep in my fridge.
Then I can make a
gimlet with the gin.
I can make a classic
daiquiri with the rum,
and I can make a Margarita
with the tequila.
And I've basically just
got lime, simple syrup,
and three bottles of spirits.
And then those each--
they're all citrusy,
so you got a
problem there if you
want something
more booze-forward
if your mood changes.
But those all three
tastes very different,
depending on what spirit
you have, and yet you've
still kept it kind of simple
and your tools are the same.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
Yeah, that's one thing
that people forget as they're
like shopping for their home
bar.
Most of the classic
cocktails out there
are sours, meaning they
have citrus in them.
So like when I go
home on a Friday,
I make sure to stop
by the grocery store,
and I get an orange,
I get a couple lemons,
and I get a couple limes.
I don't know what I'm going
to have when I get home,
but I'm going to be
mad if I suddenly
decide that I want to daiquiri
and I didn't get any freaking
limes.
And I can't make the
daiquiri without the limes.
So you need the produce as well.
So like you'll need mint if
you suddenly want mint juleps.
And the same with a lot
of other drinks, too.
And make sure you
have sugar on hand.
I don't know who runs out
of sugar, but make sure
you have sugar on hand.
And well, you definitely need
a bottle of angostura bitters,
or else you're pretty
much out of business.
It goes into too many things.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Or
good tonics for easy gin
and tonics or things
like that, vodka tonics.
That's always easy.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Yeah.
And if you like whisky or if you
have friends who like whisky,
a carefully chosen
nice bottle of bourbon
and a bottle of scotch,
which you don't need to mix.
Just pour it out, and
everybody's happy.
AUDIENCE: I usually
like to drink
stuff that's pretty classical
cocktails, like Old Fashioneds
or something like that.
If I'm going someplace, and so
it will be typically off menu,
would that be considered
like hazardous,
given that it's not actually
like listed on the menu?
Or would I expect most bars to
be able to do classical things?
ROBERT SIMONSON: You're
ordering an Old Fashioned
or a Manhattan or something?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
Yeah, they usually
don't bother-- a
lot of places don't
bother to put it on the menu
because it's so well known.
If you are very particular
about those drinks
and you like them a certain
way and not another way,
there's no problem asking
the bartender, saying,
I'm thinking about
an Old Fashioned.
How do you make it here?
They'll happily tell you
exactly how they make it,
and then you'll know, OK,
I want that drink, no,
I don't want that drink.
AUDIENCE: That's really helpful,
because I usually go someplace,
and I get it, and
it's not [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT SIMONSON:
And these days, they
take that drink very
seriously, but everyone
makes it slightly different.
VIRGINIA MILLER: That's true.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Different
bitters, a different sweetener.
It's OK to ask, like,
what bourbon do you
use in your Old Fashioned here?
What's your house bourbon?
They don't mind answering
questions like that.
They like it.
AUDIENCE: They have it
on tap in some places,
too, which is amazing.
ROBERT SIMONSON: They do, yeah.
I see that a lot.
I was just in Cincinnati,
and there was a place
that had Old Fashions on tap.
That's because people
order them too fast.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'm just going
to ask a quick question,
then give it to you.
Again, I'm not cool.
I was the last person
to discover Trick Dog,
so take this with
a grain of salt.
But I've noticed something
on menus recently,
which is shrubs,
and sort of very
like, our shrub is
made with artisanal,
organic blah-blah-blah.
So just maybe you could talk
a little bit about shrubs.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Well,
vinegar-based, as well as-- it
could go a couple directions.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Yeah,
mainly vinegar, though.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Mainly
vinegar, though, and--
ROBERT SIMONSON: Vinegar,
fruit, and sugar.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah,
vinegar, fruit, and sugar.
Exactly.
And what I find, what
I love about them,
is it often gives a real bracing
kind of backbone to a drink.
So even if you're getting
something tall and refreshing,
it will add this nice-- if they
do it right and it's balanced,
it will add this kind of
oomph to it with the vinegar.
But some, you get
them, and it tastes
like you're drinking
kombucha or all vinegar.
And then others, you can't
taste the vinegar at all,
and then I say, why
I call it a shrub?
But it's actually a historic
thing that goes back to 1800s.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Yeah,
at least 200 years.
VIRGINIA MILLER: At least.
ROBERT SIMONSON: This is how
people-- they had their fruit.
They don't have a refrigerator.
How do you preserve it?
You throw it in some
vinegar with some sugar,
and then in the spring,
they just drink it.
And it's usually used as a
replacement for another acid.
So if you don't have citrus
in your cocktail performing
the acidic role, a
shrub will do that.
And bartenders
rediscovered shrubs
about six or seven years ago.
And some make a
specialty out of it.
VIRGINIA MILLER: And it's a
way that maybe summer fruit
can last a little longer.
I'm still seeing strawberry
shrubs and things
like that on menus right
now, even though they've just
gone out of season.
It preserves it a
few weeks longer.
ROBERT SIMONSON: But if you see
something with a shrub in it
on the menu, make sure you
like something that gives you
a little pucker, kind of mm.
An old cocktail?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Most of the
big classics have come back.
There's a wonderful old cocktail
from like the '10s or '20s
that I always like
called Cameron's Kick.
It's got orgeat in it,
which is an almond syrup.
It's got lemon juice and
I believe a combination
of bourbon and scotch.
Is that right?
VIRGINIA MILLER: That
sounds right, yeah.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
And it seems-- it's
an odd duck, because
it's a whisky sour
but with orgeat slipped
in, which is something
you associate with tiki drinks.
And I know a lot of bartenders
who like this drink.
And you see it pop up
every now and then.
The problem was it was
never really a classic.
It's just a minor drink.
But minor drinks from
the past have come back,
like the Jungle Bird, a
completely obscure tiki drink
that is all over the place now.
So that's one I'd like to see.
What would you like to see
come back there, Virginia?
VIRGINIA MILLER: Oh, goodness.
Well, I'd have to think
about this for a minute.
But I was going to say, one
thing, a modern classic,
that I loved in the last
section of your book--
at the end of his book,
there's a section on cocktails
that you think maybe did deserve
a little more recognition.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
Yeah, that I had
hoped that would become
modern classics, yes.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah, and one
is Owen Westman's Laphroaig
Project.
And I remember that
at Bourbon and Branch
when it first opened when Owen
was still bartending there.
And I used to get that one
all the time, and I loved it.
ROBERT SIMONSON: It was like
a sensation for a nanosecond
in San Francisco.
For a year, everyone was
drinking the Laphroaig Project,
which is a little
Laphroaig, peaty whisky.
It's got yellow chartreuse,
green chartreuse, lemon juice
or lime juice?
VIRGINIA MILLER: I
think it's lemon.
ROBERT SIMONSON: It's
in the back of the book.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah,
it's in the book.
ROBERT SIMONSON:
Delicious drink.
Expensive drink.
You need expensive
stuff like the Laphroaig
and the chartreuse.
And the chartreuse is like
gonna set you back $150
just to make the drink.
And that's why you don't
see it on menus anymore.
But it is really,
really delicious.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah, I love
that you included that one,
because that's one I miss.
Penicillin Time, too.
I kind of thought I
liked it almost as much.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Yeah, the
who made it is Australian.
He worked at Bourbon
and Branch for a while.
But he got homesick and
went back to Melbourne.
And he took the drink with him.
I guess they drink it
a lot in Melbourne now.
AUDIENCE: What legal
[INAUDIBLE] still exists?
ROBERT SIMONSON: There
were a lot for a while.
Prohibition left a nasty residue
all over the legal system
in this country, weird
laws, not just things
like you couldn't open
your bar on Sunday
or liquor stores couldn't
open on election day.
There was like one weird
law in the South, one
of those Southern states,
South Carolina, I think,
where you could only
mix cocktails out
of those little
mini liquor bottles.
[LAUGHTER]
I guess this was supposed
to impede drinking.
You had problems here
in San Francisco.
There was one point where
the health department started
cracking down and
saying that infusions,
where you put something
in a spirit to flavor it,
were illegal.
And this was like a
crisis for a while
until some politician got
it overturned or something.
VIRGINIA MILLER: Mhm.
Yeah, the Distillers Guild
and a few different groups
were working on it.
ROBERT SIMONSON: There was
another time in New York where
like the health department came
in and said, oh, my god, you're
making drinks with raw eggs,
and we're shutting you down.
[LAUGHTER]
So there were a lot, but
they're mainly gone now.
They're mainly gone, these
legal hurdles, aren't they?
VIRGINIA MILLER: Yeah, there
are still a few weird ones.
I mean, we've had
some recent successes
in California in terms of
now distilleries are actually
able to sell their own
bottles at their distillery
and do that sort of thing.
ROBERT SIMONSON: Oh. yeah,
that was totally unfair.
And the wine country,
you go to the winery,
and of course you get a taste
and you can drink there.
It took so long
for the distillers
to get the same privilege.
But now you can
go there and have
a little sip of their
wares and decide
whether you want
to buy it while you
take a tour of the distillery.
VIRGINIA MILLER: But
there are still states,
like Oklahoma-- there's
that three-tiered system,
and things have a high mark-up.
There are still a lot of issues
with spirits in some states.
It makes it tough for the bars,
because they pay so much more
for their basic spirits.
ROBERT SIMONSON: You do
have the control states.
The control states don't
want to give that up.
It's too much money.
It's ridiculous that-- I
mean, Pennsylvania it has
been laboring under this
ridiculously arcane system,
where you can only buy
liquor through the state.
And the state buys
what it chooses to buy.
So bartenders basically
have to smuggle
in this stuff from
other states that they
want to use in their drinks.
I don't see that going away--
VIRGINIA MILLER: Unfortunately.
ROBERT SIMONSON: --for the
states that still have it.
I think it's about 16
states are still-- yeah,
all the liquor is bought
through the state,
and you have to go
to package stores.
Yeah.
One more?
AUDIENCE: Anything
like [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT SIMONSON:
A trend with a lot
of bars these days is low-proof
cocktails, low ABV cocktails,
which can be delicious.
These are cocktails that
are made with liquors that
have a lower alcohol content.
Most spirits are 40% or above.
But if you're dealing
with some of the liqueurs,
you're like 20% and below.
If you don't mind
starting with one of those
just to see a greater variety
of what they're doing,
you'll probably
last one drink more.
Do remember, the brown,
bitter, and stirred drinks,
you also-- get ones
that are on the rocks.
You can sip at them
for a long time.
And you can spend a
half hour on that drink.
As opposed to the
ones served up,
you pretty much have to
drink within 10 minutes
or else it goes warm.
So there's a couple tips.
Thank you so much for coming.
I hope you enjoy the book.
Thank you, Virginia.
VIRGINIA MILLER:
Thank you, Robert.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]